foreign
[Music]
this is Ian King live the top stories
today
Prince Harry to take Center
age in his fight
s for the Duke of Sussex and mirror
group newspapers are to set out their
opening arguments today
the main business store is oil prices
rise as Saudi Arabia says it will cut
production by a million barrels a day in
July
a BP and Heathrow among companies
joining a new business Council to
challenge the beleaguered CBI
plus new car registrations in the UK up
for the 10th consecutive month
[Music]
a very good morning from the high court
where Prince Harry is preparing to give
evidence in court this week in his
alleged phone hacking case against the
publisher of the Mirror newspaper Prince
Harry will be the first senior Royal to
appear as a witness at the high court
since 1891 when the heir to the throne
Prince Edward was called to give
evidence in a case about cheating at
cards what Prince Harry's lawyers and
mirror group newspapers legal team are
due to set out their opening arguments
on the case today the Duke of Sussex has
said it's his life's work to change the
Tabloid media landscape Prince Harry
claims journalists at the mirror Group
which includes the Sunday Mirror and
Sunday people were linked to methods
including phone hacking so-called
blagging or gaining information by
deception and use of private
investigators for unlawful activities
well you only need to at the number of
cameras here outside the high court to
see the true historic nature of this
moment we are expecting Prince Harry to
be in court today so far no sign of the
Duke of Sussex we're standing by
awaiting for his arrival in the meantime
we can speak to our Royal correspondent
Laura bundock who's with me and will be
throughout the week good to see you
Laura such a big moment for Prince Harry
this is an absolutely huge moment for
him and walking just around the corner
from this court is this huge statue of
Prince Albert I was reminded it was his
son Edward VII then Prince of Wales who
was the last senior Royal to give
evidence taking the witness box taking
the witness stand at the high court and
now we have over 130 years later Prince
Harry coming to do just that he has
spoken at length about the huge distress
he felt the media intrusion into his
personal life into his family life into
his professional life
Ian King
yeah in a moment we will be coming to
the main business news stories but first
we're going to another development in
the Philips Schofield Scandal this
engulfed ITV in the last few moments
Holly Willoughby has returned to this
morning and has been talking about the
Fallout since her former co-presenter
admitted to having an affair with a
younger member of Staff joining me now
is our correspondent Melania
veselinovich who is at television Center
we're going to hear from Holly
Willoughby first though
firstly are you okay I hope so it feels
very strange indeed sitting here without
Phil and I imagine that you might have
been feeling a lot like I have
shaken troubled let down worried for the
well-being of people on all sides of
what's been going on and full of
questions
you me and all of us at this morning
gave our love and support to someone who
was not telling the truth
who acted in a way that they themselves
felt that they had to resign from ITV
and step down from a career that they
loved
that is a lot to process
and it's equally hard to see the toll
that it's taken on their own Mental
Health
I think what unites us all now is a
desire to heal for the health and
well-being of everyone
I hope that as we start this new chapter
and get back to a place of warmth and
Magic that this show holds for all of us
we can find strength in each other
and from my heart can I just say thank
you for all of your kind messages and
thank you for being here this morning
myself Josie Derma Allison Craig and
every single person that works on this
show will continue to work hard every
single day to bring you to the show that
we love so on that note Josie
you bring it in bring it in thank you
thank you I need a joke oh thank you
thank you thank you
our correspondent Melania vesselinovich
is at television Center in West London
which is where the ITV Studio that
broadcast this morning is Milena
work clearly an attempt there by Holly
Willoughby to really draw a line under
this Scandal that's really been
unfolding over the next few weeks she
was also integral part of it she had to
come out on Instagram and say that she
indeed had no idea that Phillips
Coffield was having this affair with
this much younger colleague she said
that that was very hurtful because he
lied directly to her something that he
had in a subsequent interview confirmed
so now coming out for the first time on
the sofa since this Scandal broke out a
real attempt to say that you know the
ITV family want to put this behind them
the feeling of also I suppose betrayal
from one of his her most closest
co-workers that this affair was indeed
going on and that she was indeed lied to
about that and a real attempt to just
put it all behind them and move on with
the program but of course that really
won't be possible because there is an
external you that will take place led by
a barrister into how ITV handled that
investigation into rumors of that Affair
when it first emerged back in 2019 and
2020 and not only that Dean Carolyn
McCall the ITV CEO will also have to
answer questions from MPS on the 14th of
June on safeguarding practices at ITV as
well as how it handles complaints
because there have been many complaints
of a toxic workplace culture coming from
for example one of the show's former
resident doctors Dr ranj Singh who said
that he was a whistleblower on that
culture who was then managed out now we
also heard from Martin Frizzell the one
of the show's editors who said that that
was perhaps School settling so today
Holly willoughby's appearance just
trying to move past the last two weeks
move on and and just get on with her job
thanks Milena
well we will be coming to the business
news very shortly I promise you but in
the meantime we're going back now to uh
Sally Lockwood at the high court Sally
thanks very much Ian bounce around
between breaking news there but luckily
for us we didn't miss that arrival shot
to Prince Harry still no sign of the
Duke of Sussex but of course a very very
big day for Prince Harry as his lawyer
begins at laying out his case against
the merry group newspaper and of course
we will be hearing from Prince Harry
himself appearing in the witness a box
from tomorrow could be sooner we don't
know but certainly we'll be hearing from
him this week a big moment for Prince
Harry and a very brave moment many would
say we're going to bring you all of the
events as they unfold in court live here
on the Sky News Channel and also on our
live blog which you can follow on the
Sky News Mobile app now throughout the
events today and this week I'll be
joined by our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock and Jonathan Coe media lawyer
great to have you both with us I cut you
off their lawyer because of that lawyer
because of that breaking news on ITV but
let's just pick up uh you were talking
about the historic nature and the
significant and significance of this
moment for Prince Harry yes I mean he
will attempt to argue that from a very
young age so the first of his 33
articles is when he was not even a
teenager his mother was still alive had
this huge amount of intrusion into his
private his personal his family his
professional life intrusion that
resulted in newspaper articles he is
claiming can only have been written with
or with information that was illegally
obtained and these are articles a lot of
them about his relationship with his
ex-girlfriend Chelsea Davey some of them
about his time in the Army some of them
about Prince William they span a huge
and very important part of his life we
know a lot about Harry don't we we've
had his Memoir we've had the Oprah
interview we've had the Netflix series
The subsequent interviews he's given but
it has always been on his terms he will
find himself in Alien territory when he
comes here takes the witness stand and
will have his whole argument try tried
to be torn apart by the lawyers for the
mirror group newspapers they will be
picking apart what he says they will be
denying that they use these illegal
activities for him and they will be
trying to take him down a rabbit hole if
you like he he will not want to go off
proof he will have his statement but
they will be goading him to try and say
things that will get him to reveal
information and don't forget some of
these stories are about pretty explosive
parts of his life it'll be huge
Revelations but as we know Harry has a
much higher purpose here he wants to as
he puts it change the media landscape he
says this is his life's work that he
believes not only were they acting
inappropriately they were breaking the
law and he wants some of the senior
newspaper Executives who knew he says
what was going on thrown into jail those
are his exact words that is his bigger
purpose here yeah certainly Jonathan
Asura was saying there you know this is
deeply personal for Prince Harry he's
talked in depth before in media
interviews about how the British
tabloids have impacted his life the role
that he believes they played in his
mother's death
he wants his day in court but of course
he will have been offered opportunities
to settle before this moment won't he
the key thing about this case is it was
never going to settle and one of the
reasons why Mr Justice fancorp decided
to take this amongst the whole plethora
of cases because it was clear to him it
wasn't going to settle and this is the
great dread for the mirror because the
other newspapers have been able to buy
off claimants
and in that basis you know they've been
able to cover up their wrongdoing partly
by spinning far sums and money in
compensation but also spending bar sums
of money on lawyers which is a bit of an
irony given the complaints they make
about the use of lawyers to protect
other people's privacy but the key thing
here is that that on behalf I think of a
lot of other people Prince Harry is
being a bit of a warrior and saying you
know what I have been a particular
victim of press abuse I'm going to pick
up the better I'm going to fight like I
thought the Taliban I'm going to fight
them and it is that serious for memory
Executives because course Executives
some News International ended up in jail
well at least Andy Coulson did yeah and
as far as he's concerned I imagine that
he has Piers Morgan in his crosshairs
who's popping up as a sort of like Bank
Rose ghost and he'll be hoping that one
way or another at least there'll be a
finding effect by the judge that Piers
Morgan knew what was going on yeah and
certainly for many after the leverson
inquiry many felt that there was
unfinished business it's going be very
interesting week indeed Laura Jonathan
back to you shortly thanks very much
indeed and we're going to be bringing
you a live events as they unfold in
court there's no camera in court but we
have a Sky News team in there who'll be
bringing us events as they unfold on our
Sky News live blog on the mobile app and
we'll be breaking those lines and giving
you analysis here on the Sky News
Channel as well I'll be back with more
on the Prince Harry court case very
shortly but in the meantime you can scan
the QR code on your screen right now
which will take you to continuing
coverage on that live blog and they'll
also be a special program each evening
at 9 00 PM this week examining the case
and exactly what we've heard in court
back to Ian King
thanks Sally now the British Chambers of
Commerce has announced a new business
Council to rival the beleaguered CBI the
BCC says it's part of a new National
offer to businesses among the companies
who've signed up a BP Heathrow Drax and
the hotel operator IHG well joining me
now Siobhan she's director general of
the British Chambers of Commerce Siobhan
welcome to you I mean this is all very
uh very uh opportunistic timing isn't it
the Beast the CBI is facing a vote on
its future tomorrow
morning
um yes indeed the CBI are facing a vote
on its future tomorrow and they've got
some key challenges but we absolutely
wish them well we hope it happens for
them as they have said they've got a
long road ahead to fix things but you
know we are not competing with the CBI
we want to see them do well Business
Council that we are launching today is
about giving business a voice we are at
a really crucial moment we're a pivotal
point for our economy we're probably
what a year 18 months away from a
general election and it's the time is of
the essence you know this is about
policy development it's about bringing
business together around the table so we
can look at some of those key economic
challenges and opportunities of course
and feed them into the the election
manifestos for next year one of the
great strengths traditionally of the
British Chambers of Commerce is that
very Regional aspect to it you have the
regional Chambers fit uh you know
reporting into the sort of national body
isn't this going to dilute the sort of
localness of the BCC
uh so our chamber Network Ian just to
say they don't report into the BCC they
are our members we are their Collective
voice and this actually will do the
opposite it it all our business council
members are members of their local
Chambers it is crucial that they are
part of that National local Regional
infrastructure as well as our
International strength around the world
so this is an enhancement this is an
addition to their local membership of
their Chambers and and I mean they are
telling us that that strength that we
have hundreds of people around the
country helping businesses every day is
why the chambers uh the British Chambers
of Commerce is such a great organization
to work with you've said that you're not
trying to compete with the CBI here but
the timing of this as I say looks
incredibly uh opportunistic the CBI
facing this crucial vote tomorrow I mean
you surely are it looks like you're
trying to take some of their members
almost
this work has been long in development
as you know I've been in this job a
couple of years now and you know the
last five six years we've seen brexit
covid rampant inflation energy price
issues trouble getting people business
has been facing a lot of problems and at
the end of last year we started the
development of our new campaign where
business belongs we launched that at our
Global conference three weeks ago we had
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor of exchequer
we had the governor of the bank of
England we had kirstma there talking
about it and this is the next step in
that campaign we we launched our
economic advisory panel last week and
next week we will be doing a report for
the climate change committee so it's all
part of business as usual for us
how much will you be charging those
companies that sign up to this business
Council will it be less than the CBI was
charging for membership
uh well I I don't know what the CBI
charges for membership
um I don't believe they publish that and
um that you know that was a commercially
sensitive conversations
um but the point here is it's about
ensuring that business have a choice and
they have a voice and business needs to
be represented now they their voice
needs to be heard by government we need
to look at the economic challenges
digital Revolution green Innovation
people at work our place in the world
and our local high streets and that's
what the Business Council is all about
Siobhan you just said you wish the CBI
well I mean it's perfectly possible that
if this vote goes against them tomorrow
they may have to wind themselves up but
if they don't you're going to have to
work with them in future you know as
part of the so-called big five uh
trading business bodies
yes absolutely we've worked with the CBI
for the last two years almost weekly
basis as the B5 in with government and
uh we are hoping that the CBI get
themselves back on the road and we look
forward to working with them again in
the future
all right Siobhan gotta leave it there
appreciate you joining me today thank
you thank you our senior trade ministers
from across the Commonwealth are meeting
in London today top of the agenda
digital trade and how to improve
international access for businesses in
54 countries to new Global markets well
the main focus is on how to ditch paper
documents for Digital Data flows which
could reportedly help boost trade
Revenue by billions of pounds will
joining me now is Chris Southworth he's
Secretary General of the international
Chambers of Commerce UK Chris welcome to
you it is the case right now that all
International Trade documents have to be
in physical paper form isn't it all the
commercial trade documents currently
with the exception of seven countries
have to be on paper and that's part of
the problem of course when we're trying
to modernize the trading system you know
this is ultimately all about making sure
that the trading system is fit for
purpose for the 21st century and of
course that means going digital we're
just inheriting a system that was set up
a hundred years ago that of course
revolves around paper the laws we use
actually go back to 1882 to give you an
idea so of course we need to reform laws
remove all the barriers and enable the
whole system to go paperless although
there are some countries that I think
France Germany and indeed here in the UK
we are moving towards a paperless yeah
there's been tremendous progress over
the last three years it's quite
extraordinary really the UK actually
started the process so the British
British government with the G7
ministerial commitment to remove legal
barriers so this year we'll see France
Germany Japan U.S and UK all get all
remove legal barriers uh by the end of
the year so what's going to be the
obstacles towards Rolling this out
across the Commonwealth uh well the
biggest obstacle is capacity in a
network like the Commonwealth and that's
pretty much the same worldwide every
country is starting in a slightly
different point some are more advanced
with with infrastructure in place others
less so and quite often there's not
enough legal capacity so this is about
all of us working together now the
private sector and governments to to
make this happen because we have the
resources to do it we just need to work
together we know what the problems are
how much do you reckon this is costing
businesses around the world this
insistence on physical paper oh it's
enormous absolutely enormous I think if
you look at it in first in terms of the
benefits that gives you a good idea
across the Commonwealth alone it's 1.1
trillion we're talking about in terms of
trade growth in the UK it's two it's 224
billion in efficiency savings and 25
billion and Sterling uh in the
Commonwealth dollars yeah across the G7
that's seven billion yeah seven trillion
sorry it's huge and that and that's the
inefficiency in the system everyone
always asks me why are the numbers so
big well it's because we're working on a
very Antiquated uh set of processes and
it's just about leaping into the 21st
century and using technology in a
smarter way and I gather on a lot of
transactions there can be as many as 40
physical pieces of paper flying around
at any oh it's unbelievable I don't
think people outside trade realize how
Antiquated it is it's extraordinary I
mean it can take up to two to three
months to transact it could be dealing
with 40 different paper documents and
those are dealt with manually in the
main in the main it's all manual check
check check check across multiple
parties it's just incredibly inefficient
and it's totally unnecessary that's the
interesting part you know once you use
modern technology and modern systems
which already exist by the way none of
that's necessary because it's you know
we don't need to talk about documents it
should be about data yeah and of course
then you can actually remove a whole
Suave of the process by just using data
more efficiently between business and
government so I hope to Mystic I that
you're going to get an agreement this
week uh I'm I'm very optimistic the
Bangladesh government is our lead I'm
the co-lead with them from the business
side and they're making the proposal to
train ministers today at uh midday so
we're confident that you know there's no
dispute about digitalization across
trade ministers it's just about being
very very clear what is the specific
task to take us to the next next step
forward and importantly unlock business
so that we can all play our full part in
the process all right Chris well best of
luck with that good to see you this week
some other business news stories for you
now a new car registrations in the UK
Rose last month for the 10th consecutive
month it's the longest uninterrupted
period of growth for the industry since
2015. the Society of motor manufacturers
and Traders said their 145 204 new car
registrations in May that was up 16.7
percent on May last year but was still
down 21 on the same month in 2019 prior
to the pandemic well the growth was
driven by large Fleet registrations with
registrations to private buyers actually
falling by half of one percent the
best-selling card during the month was
the Ford Puma followed by the Nissan
Qashqai and the Vauxhall mocha
the global drinks giant diagio said this
morning that Deborah crew it's incoming
chief executive has taken the role on an
interim basis with immediate effects
when it comes after it emerged that the
current chief executive sir Ivan menezes
suffered a setback following emergency
surgery for a stomach ulcer surviven was
due to retire from Diageo whose Brands
include Johnny Walker scotch whiskey
Gordon's gin Smirnoff vodka and Guinness
at the end of the month Diageo said our
thoughts are with our much-loved
colleague Ivan and his family and we
obviously sent our best to him as well
regular guest on this program
the Australian arm of the business
services joint PWC this morning named
dozens of current and former staff
involved in the leak of confidential
government tax plans they're said to
include nine Partners who have stood
down and 63 staff and partners who
received emails containing information
on charges to multinational tax
avoidance laws that confidential
information was subsequently used by The
Firm to win new business or the Scandal
has rocked PWC whose conduct has been
referred by the country's government to
the Australian federal police
foreign
is trading high after Saudi Arabia
announced a voluntary production cut of
1 million barrels per day us from next
month a barrel of Brent crude currently
will charge it will cost you 77.85 cents
a barrel that's up two and a quarter
percent on the session on the equity
markets following Wall Street strong
showing on Friday evening stocks in the
Asia Pacific region had a solid session
overnight the Nikkei in the top left
hand corner there so you can see it up
two and a quarter percent that's another
33 year high well in Europe stocks have
been mixed this morning so far as you
can see the cat current in France and
the maybe Milan in negative territory
the ducks in Germany and the Ibex in
Madrid in positive territory run that's
all pretty flatish looking at that
though to be honest talking points today
include via play the Swedish streaming
company it shares around 58 in Stockholm
following a profits warning that has led
to the departure of its chief executive
we're here in London as you can see the
ftse 100 is currently uh some 40 points
to the good nearly up half of 1 percent
the oil heavy weights you will not be
surprised to learn are lending support
there the leading Blue Chip gainer in
percentage terms though is the fund
manager Aberdeen and that's after
announced a shared buyback program worth
up to 150 million pounds a lot of uh
things going on outside the footsie Asos
the online fashion retailer the shares
up ten and a half percent that's after
the Sunday Times reported it received a
takeover approach from the Turkish
company trendio in December elsewhere
the Pharma company in divio is ahead by
some nine and a half percent after it
settled a U.S lawsuit you might recall
we had the CEO of that particular
company on the program fairly recently
meanwhile Dr Martens the shares there
investors putting the boot in the shares
of another two and three-quarter percent
following Friday's disappointing trading
update on the Foreign Exchange Market so
it's all about the US dollar really
really on the front foot following
Friday stronger than expected U.S jobs
data the pound is off nearly half of one
percent lower against the dollar uh the
euro is off by uh just under six of one
percent against the Greenback meanwhile
the pound also down by 31 roughly
Against The single currency well joining
me this morning is Will Hobbs he's Chief
investment officer for UK wealth
management at Barclays well good to see
you this morning we've got to start with
the oil price I guess are you surprised
there hasn't been more of a reaction
because this is a big big chunk out of
Saudi production
yeah morning in um it's big but it's
temporary I think that's one thing to to
to bear in mind and I think that you
know one of the things about the oil
price so far this year and this goes for
sort of you know Investments more
broadly
um you know the China reopening story
has been the elephant the whale in the
bathtub
um I guess
um and so far what we've seen is that
that has been focused primarily the
reopening story and all the kind of good
news has been focused on consumer
services and that's obviously
um it's been much less investment heavy
um and therefore that has been
um it's demanded Less in the way of oil
and other Commodities so commodity
prices have been a bit weaker over the
course of the year
um and that is probably you know not
really going to change that much in the
short term certainly
um but yes interesting it is I mean the
other the other interesting things that
have come out of this I mean society's
acting unilaterally we're told that some
African countries may be forced to cut
production at some point but I mean the
big question that the sort of
geopolitical question around this is
whether Russia is forced to follow suit
at some point
but yes I mean and again this is you
know just part of an incredibly complex
uh commodity story at the moment as we
know
um and you know uh you know better than
anyone in that you know oil in a sense
is produced by a cartel you want to be
careful about uh Discerning the
motivations of that cartel account
surprise on a regular basis
um the broader picture though is really
interesting I think for the global
economy at the moment because obviously
you've got this uh you know the incoming
price to be paid uh for last year's
interest rate shock um that's still to
be determined in the U.S data last week
is still showing that the US economy is
still straining at its leash a little
bit um and then you've got this kind of
growing excitement uh on a medium term
with regards to a potential return of
productivity growth uh in the form you
know driven by uh the advances in
generative AI so Commodities stock
spawns it's a really really complicated
moment for investors to try and sort of
work their way through even though we've
got beyond the debt ceiling and some of
the other issues that were kind of
looming large yeah you raise a very good
point there well I mean the Friday jobs
numbers were we're really very very
strong I mean uh people will be amazed
given the the velocity at which the FED
has raised interest rates over the last
12 months
yeah I mean we're reminded again Ian
that you know you know labor market data
are lagging um you know they're it's
generally the last shoe to drop but yes
uh you are right there are still
considerable momentum uh in certain
parts of the US economy uh there has
been a great deal of resilience so far
to that interest rate shock and you know
I mean a real two-year interest rates
Rising by as much as they would in
decades and the space of 80 years sorry
in the space of months
um but so far like you say like Friday's
data is still telling us we'll see we'll
see a bit more today of the leading
indicator side we've got the ism surveys
uh you know business survey uh data
coming out which will give us a bit more
of a look about what's coming down the
pike but certainly you know the sense is
that U.S policymakers have still got
more to do uh to slow the US and global
economy and bring inflation back to heal
all right well gotta leave it there good
to talk to you as ever thank you
High Court where Prince Harry is due to
take center stage in his fight against
the Tabloid press
foreign
[Music]
hello again from the high court where
legal proceedings are just getting
underway in Prince Harry's case against
the publisher of the Mirror newspaper
now Prince Harry's lawyers and mirror
group newspapers legal team are
beginning to set out their opening
arguments on the case the Duke of Sussex
claims journalists at the mirror Group
which includes the Sunday Mirror and
Sunday people were linked to methods
including phone hacking so-called
blagging or gaining information by
deception and the use of private
investigators for unlawful activities
well we're going to be bringing you all
the events from inside Court live
throughout the day and throughout the
week here on the Sky News Channel and
also on our live blog that you can
follow on the Sky News Mobile app and
with me throughout will be our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock and media
lawyer Jonathan code Laura a big moment
for Prince Harry this week he hasn't
arrived yet today but just Begin by
outlining what we can expect today
what we can expect to hear is the
arguments uh for his legal team in terms
of his case to answer and then how
mirror group are going to respond to
that but for Harry himself this is a
massive personal moment he has spoken
we've heard haven't we how the intrusion
of the press the fact he believes that
his life was being hacked into his
private life his personal life
everything he did at work as well from a
very young age that he had he struggled
he became suspicious he couldn't trust
people close to him he felt that and
there was nowhere that was off limits in
his life he suffered huge bouts of
depression and paranoia as a result of
this and he is now on this personal
mission to try and change things look I
don't think there is anybody here today
who would argue in favor of phone
hacking clearly it was illegal and it
was not a practice that any journalist
would condone today but I think Harry
has this much bigger Mission here he
wants to make change he's Mercedes going
to make his life's work to see those
very senior Executives who he believes
and alleges knew exactly what was going
on he says and he's argued that they not
only knew what was going on they tried
to conceal it they tried to hide it and
in some cases they were even
commissioning phone hacking and there's
an unlawful information gathering so
this is a huge moment for him and he
will have two days in the witness stand
where he will be very exposed everything
we've heard from Harry he's been in
control of the narrative he will not
have that same control here and I've
never appeared as a witness at the high
Corp you can only imagine once you're in
there you are totally on your own it is
very exposing and he will be facing some
very very rigorous legal questioning
okay Laura thanks and Jonathan you know
as Laura was saying they're very very
different to a media interview you of
course understand only too well the
goings-on inside court and and mirror
group newspapers lawyers will very much
focus on what Harry knew and where right
first of all I've also been
cross-examined twice in the witness box
uh and it's it is it's quite tough yes
the key Battleground is exactly that
Sally
so for the mirror group they're trying
to knock this out sort of on a
technicality what the mirror group want
to do is persuade the judge that the
information that Harry gathered about
all this over the years should have
triggered this case a long time before
it actually started so the law says he
should bring the case six years after
the wrongdoing
occurred but what the law also says is
if he didn't know that the wrong doing
happened and couldn't have found it out
in that time the limitation period gets
moved back so the background is Mira
saying judge look he must have known
this was going on he should have brought
the case earlier you should strike it
out Prince Harry's saying I didn't know
and I couldn't have known
now Jonathan we've had some breaking
news this hour as well from ITV Holly
Willoughby back on air on this morning
after of course the scandalous embroiled
ITV and Philip Schofield this week this
week in recent weeks now you are Phillip
schofield's lawyer I can't have you on
without asking you about this um how do
you um what do you make of the recent
media coverage and how have you found
your role as his lawyer Myra was was
very simple and that's to get the truth
out on Philip's behalf
there has been an awful lot of bad stuff
in the media about Philip which isn't
true which I know because I've had
access to all the relevance of
information so that's the limit of it
getting the truth out and trying to
knock out as much of the stuff which
isn't true as possible
too much for Del
endel on that Jonathan Laura we're back
to Sky News we'll be bringing you uh all
those events as they break from inside
Court throughout the day and throughout
the week that's it for me for now though
and we are keeping an eye out of course
for Prince Harry's arrival still no sign
of him yet and don't forget there'll
also be a special program each evening
this week at 9 00 PM examining the case
and all the events in court do stay with
us on the Sky News Channel see you very
shortly back to Ian
thanks Ellie now NatWest has just
completed a major acquisition it's
paying 144 million pounds for an 85
stake in cushion a fast-growing
Financial technology business will
cushion partners with Employers in the
provision of workplace pensions and
other savings products including Isis it
already runs pensions and other
investors for half a million employees
in the UK including staff at Asda Marx
and Spencer and Samsung will joining me
now is the co-founder and chief
executive of cushion Ben polot and Peter
Flavel the chief executive of NatWest
wealth businesses welcome to you both
Peter let me start with you why did you
want this business well at the NatWest
group name we Bank One in five companies
across the UK and we know that around 9
million of our personal customers pay
their salary into their current account
each month and so there's a large
opportunity in terms of the needs of
those customers and of course those
corporate customers need to have a
pension plan and we need to be where our
customers are and what Ben's put
together is an app-led server service
for pensions and Isis and workplace
financial services so you're looking
essentially to leverage this into other
uh in into is workplace pensions the
focus for you here really well workplace
financial services so includes pensions
um and we want people to understand
their whole financial life not just
their pensions but the pensions is a big
a big part of it and so there are 33
million people employed in the UK and
when they're at work somewhere there on
the internet is their pension and so we
want to be at work delivering Financial
Services to them of course your part of
the business also includes Coots and
some very high-end people this feels
like you're going more for the sort of
mass Market this is a retail and mass
affluent proposition fundamentally
people at high net worth still need
pensions but this fundamentally is about
retail and affluent customers so Ben
what was the origin of the business
um so I often say the story of cushion
is the story of an indignant actuary and
that being me
um I I went to set up an Isa for myself
and with my Actuarial background thought
that ought to be a straightforward
process
um I was aghast at the quality of
information that was being served up to
me well no relation to the information I
knew big companies used to invest their
own money
um and set about applying my Actuarial
skills and building cushion to make it
easier for normal people but it's quite
a thing to from a startup position to
have people like Asda and Marx and
Spencer on on your Client List how did
you build build scale absolutely we've
been delighted absolutely delighted so
we we've
um our pitch was essentially it's
wonderful that all employers provide uh
help their employees save for retirement
but why don't you also help save your
your employees safe to get on the
housing ladder or save for your next
holiday rather than putting on the
credit card and the response we
generally got from employers will yeah
that's a point I don't know why we don't
do that and
that's a big part of the ingredients
that have got as to where we've got to
obviously there's a cost of living
crisis going on right now a lot of
people may not be prioritizing saving
are you seeing any evidence of that on
on your platform no not at all it's been
remarkable actually how strongly pension
contributions have held up through the
cost of living crisis and in fact it's
shown a spotlight on the importance of
from an employer's perspective getting
value for money out of the amount of
money that you're putting into your
employees pensions on their behalf and
really getting a pension scheme that
they value and engage in and can see the
benefit of is crucially important to
Employers in this cost of living you're
nodding along there Peter well and the
one of the words that Ben just uses
engaged and so we've got to get people
to understand they need to engage with
their pension it's not something that
their employer provides to them actually
it's their part of money and they need
to understand how important that is to
their long-term Financial lives the
other part of that is as your pension
pot increases actually for your own
carbon footprint a considerable part of
your carbon footprint is the way that
those those monies are invested as well
is currently loss making cushion is
going to be turning it into a profitable
business a priority for you is this all
about building wider scaling than that
West group assault well certainly it's
going to be profitable um Ian that's uh
that is the requirement uh we've already
got half a million customers uh in
cushion uh already and we think we can
build it to several times uh that site
there's a lot of talk in the air right
now about potentially compelling people
to uh or pension schemes to put some of
their money into a British growth fund
Rachel Reeves wants to see it for
example what are your thoughts on that
so I think the principle of investing in
ways that help people's lives in the way
they live is a really
um positive thing
um I the analogy I like to use it's like
investing in your own home
um as opposed to investing in your
neighbor's home it's just a kind of
logical
um obvious thing for me
um so we're supportive of the principle
of encouraging uh investment in the UK
um uh the mechanism through which that's
done whether it's compulsion or other
mechanisms or a bit more um uh
yeah Peter well I'm I'm in the incentive
basket and I don't think things should
be uh made uh compulsory trustees should
be making the right commercial decisions
around the long-term performance of the
fund but what is important is we've got
too many Master trusts and too many
small pots so as funds consolidate that
and they're larger that would enable
them to have an allocation to longer
dated more liquid uh Investments so that
consolidation is important and yeah it's
interesting you should say you think
that's coming I mean there's been a lot
of talk again among the politicians
about this you think that's coming down
the road I think it should come down the
road yes all right Peter Ben good to see
you both this morning thank you thank
you
well still to come here on Ian King live
the first UK based medicinal cannabis
manufacturer and that's his four-year
result stay with us
[Music]
okay well the reason we're here today is
that we have a search warrant for your
house
okay all right uh do you know what this
might be about
no idea
it's about uh possible mishandling of
classified information
okay so there was a transcript and all
the dialogue in the movie comes directly
verbatim from the transcript that was on
June 3rd 2017 that the FBI surprised
reality at her home she was living in
Augusta Georgia she was working at the
NSA there several weeks before she had
printed out this classified information
she saw that did prove that there had
been a Russian interference in
specifically in Florida in attempts to
get into the election
um and affect it so she had printed that
out and mailed it to a news outlet and
then several weeks later the FBI show up
at her house so we start essentially
with her a little earlier that morning
but that day of June 3rd and then the
FBI roll up and this kind of surreal
actual conversation and interrogation
unfolds in her yard and at her house I
mean they're first they're just being a
little cage and they keep making it very
conversational and they chat with her a
lot about her dogs and where her cats
are but you know then they're constantly
sort of awful also asking these other
questions and they they do say we're
year for some classified information but
for a very long time she plays it very
cool in real life you know she plays it
very cool with them too so you don't
really know exactly what what is going
on for so long because she really stays
head to head with them and it just it
sometimes is weirdly funny and then they
talk about CrossFit for a while but they
always come back to this kind of more
penetrating question so you can't ever
really relax and she can't ever really
relax
[Music]
Global insight
made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now 10 days ago it was
confirmed that Germany is in recession
after Europe's biggest economy was
buffeted by the twin blows of higher
interest rates and higher energy prices
one good barometer of German Business
Health is serious real estate the ftse
250 owner and operator of business and
industrial parks both in Germany and
here in the UK today it reported a
pre-tax profit of 87 million euros for
the year to the end of March that was
done from 168.9 million euros in the
same period a year earlier and that
reflected property revaluations were
joining me now is Andrew Coombs the
chief executive of Sirius real estate
Andrew welcome to you I'm clearly
headline profits affected by valuations
but what's going on beneath the surface
well morning in thank you very much for
having me on this morning
Sirius as you know is an unbalance sheet
play operating in Germany in the UK and
really we make money in two ways firstly
it's through re-evaluation of property
but actually what we do that a lot of
companies don't is we make very
significant Opera writing profits in
this period our gross operating profit
before tax is 96 million which is 25 up
on the previous year so um you know I
always say that in time like this it's
cash that really matters property
valuation is you know until you sell
something really uh a matter of theory
what is a matter of practice is how much
cash you throw off and what we've been
able to do is increase our funds from
operations to over 100 million Euros
which means our dividend in this period
is going up by 28 which you know our
shareholders obviously think is quite a
healthy position I take from all of that
Andrew that you've been able to put up
rents despite this sort of Fairly
unpromising background we have what
we've been able to do is increase rents
across the group by just over eight
percent and we're fortunate because we
have a platform of 450 people operating
in 150 locations across two countries
and what that means is rather than doing
a lot of business with our customers
through intermediaries we can actually
get close to our customers understand
their business and understand
opportunities whereby we can commit more
value to them in terms of the services
we provide but increase the price as a
result so I guess what I'm saying is
we're not going to customers and saying
inflation says price has to go up we're
going to customers and finding out how
to deliver more services and get the
price increased as a result of that and
that's a key driver of the increase in
funds from operations and customers are
going along with that I mean have you
seen an increase in void periods
uh in the UK what we've done is we've
seen loss of about four percentage
points of occupancy whilst we've been
able to increase the rental overall by
eight percent in Germany occupancy's
being far more stable but I would say
that you know what is happening is the
range of services that customers are
looking for has actually increased
because what they're doing is they're
looking to take more from one single
supplier and try and you know make some
price efficiencies as a result of that
and that for somebody like Sirius with
over 10 000 tenants is a real
opportunity to extend the services we
offer our customers How concerned are
you about the the state of the German
economy right now do you think this is
going to be a long drawn out recession
or a fairly shallow short one well it's
quite interesting because obviously the
headlines are all about the technical
recession that was announced um 10 10
days ago but if you look at the last
inflation print what you're actually
seeing in Germany is you're seeing
headline inflation come down from 7.6 to
6.6 and you'll see seeing the underlying
rates of inflation begin to tick down
now there is obviously contrary to what
we're seeing in the UK part of what's
driving that in in Germany is that
Germany have very much now got a hold of
the gas crisis they've replaced the loss
of Supply from nordstream one with
additional gas from Holland and also
from Norway and of course what's
happening now is liquid nitrogen is now
coming on stream over five percent of
Germany's energy is now coming from
liquid nitrogen and what that means is
the cost of gas and electricity in
Germany is coming down and that of
course is affecting the rate of headline
inflation it's very interesting that I
mean it's the Germans have been looking
for years to build an LNG terminal but
they could never get it through the
planning applications I mean it's just
gone through now does that potentially
Herald a sort of more open approach from
the German authorities towards the
planning regime I think definitely what
has happened is when the increase in
utility prices happened suddenly what it
meant was there were things that people
Supply in Germany could invest in the
previously weren't economical but
against the inflated prices the return
on investment was completely different
so I think what you've probably seen in
the last 12 months is you know things
that normally would have taken five to
ten years to achieve have been achieved
very very quickly against the backdrop
of the uh of the energy crisis all right
Andrew busy day for your results they do
appreciate you spending the time to
Chapters today thank you very much
indeed
now the use of cannabis for medicines in
the UK has grown rapidly since
government reforms opened up the
industry in 2018 well the company
Celadon Pharmaceuticals was the first
uk-based medical cannabis manufacturer
to be granted a home office license to
sell its products in the UK today it
reported a pre-tax loss of 18.1 million
pounds for 2022 I was up from one of 4.8
million pounds in 2021 Marty reflecting
higher costs well joining me now is
Arthur wagley he's managing director of
Celadon Pharmaceuticals Arthur welcome
to you where have you been putting
Capital to work primarily
morning and thanks very much for having
me on the show well I think really
today's results are a strong set of
results uh reflecting the substantial
investment we've made in this business
over the past uh 12 to 18 months since
we ipaed on the London Stock Exchange
really over the last year we have been
investing heavily in building out our
facility up in the West Midlands it's a
100 000 square foot facility to really
build the leading manufacturing base for
cannabis based medicines in the UK since
we IPO we set out some strong targets
and ambitious targets to build the
platform for growth of this business and
we're pleased to report that earlier
this year we became one of only two
companies of Our Kind licensed in the UK
buy the home office and the healthcare
Regulators to develop and to
commercially sell pharmaceutical grade
medicines to the UK market we've also
been rolling out our clinical trial and
chronic pain we onboarded the first
patients at the back end of last year
and concluded that study successfully
submitting the data to the regulator
with a really positive data for chronic
pain reduction sleep and also opioid
reduction as well so it's a strong set
of results in and really the capital has
been about expanding our facility and
our manufacturing footprint to really
set us up to uh to to deliver on revenue
and the past few weeks we've announced
our first commercial contracts for
around three million pounds of product
so a big vote of confidence in
Sutherlands ability to supply this
market now your business model entails
cultivating your own cannabis rather
than buying it in from someone else why
have you gone down that road
so it's a really good point because the
UK Market since cannabis based medicines
were legalized in 2018 has really had a
very nascent regulatory framework so
what it's seen is that the country has
basically had to import all its
cannabis-based medicines into the UK
that leads to high costs and a lot of
delays in House of stocks for patients
which is a really unacceptable situation
when you look at a lot of these patients
with severely disabling conditions
whether it's chronic pain or epilepsy
the big unlock for the UK market for
cannabis based medicines is having
domestic production of pharmaceutical
grade cultivation and products that we
can deliver to this Market that
hopefully brings the cost down it brings
the time to Market down and what we at
Standalone have invested in is indoor
Hydro cultivation and we put the systems
in place to manufacture these medicines
to a pharmaceutical grade we've also
really invested in in the clinical
trials so that we can provide the data
to the healthcare Regulators give
doctors the confidence in prescribing
and also hopefully enable reimbursements
in the NHS so that's why our strategy is
based on UK production not importing
products from abroad and it's such a big
unlock for the market obviously cannabis
plants require a lot of heat and light
presumably your energy bills have been a
headache in this period
they've slightly been higher than we
would like in but we've kept a really
tight eye in terms of cost this year and
we've actually used the the past year to
transition to renewable energy which we
announced at the start of the year and
to explore Mexico explore solar options
on sites as well
but really as we look back these are you
know these are medicines which are high
margin and really high grade
pharmaceutical medicines as well so
while cost is important what's really
important for us is developing these
medicines and getting them to patients
if we think about why there are around 8
million chronic pain sufferers in the UK
who really have no access to current
medications since 2021 when the UK
government advised against opioid usage
long-term for chronic pain so there's a
substantial Market opportunity for our
products yes cost is important but we've
got to look past the noise and look look
at the substantial Market opportunity
that we have here
okay Arthur good to talk to you this
morning thanks very much indeed for
joining me
thanks very much
well before I go just time to show you
some pictures that we've got coming in
from Dover the prime minister is on the
border Force boat in Dover he's giving a
speech during the next hour or so on
stopping small boats crossing the
channel we will hope to bring you uh
details of that
as soon as we get them much more of
course on the Sky News Mobile app and on
the website with reporting video content
and Analysis from our business team I'm
back at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning hope
very much to see you then in the
meantime do stay tuned after this short
break we're going to be going back to
Sally Lockwood at the high court for all
the latest on Prince Harry's case
against the mirror group newspapers see
you tomorrow thanks for joining me today
[Music]
foreign